[Music]
what
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
here at secret unsealed and Su TV you
know when I was in college there were
two professors separate places separate
times and also in the Seminary Dr uh
Ronald coopwood and um Dr Elden Charmers
Dr Elden Charmers was a psychiatrist Dr
coopwood was a psychiatrist also one a
teacher one a practitioner who agreed
that January 24th 4th was the most
depressing day of the year gentlemen uh
they said a number of things conspired
to make that a very depressing day one
it's a cold time of the year most of the
country is in cold weather some in
freezing weather uh by the 24th most of
your New Year's resolutions have been
broken at least once and you come to
that reality also you're struggling with
the weight you put on during the holiday
season having trouble getting it off
that's depressing also and to make
things worth those credit card bills for
the overspending during the holiday
season come to be paid and so it's a
depressing day uh say the psychiatrist
and
psychologist to the contrary the most
exciting day the most special day is
December
24th just before Christmas is the most
exciting day of the year for any number
of reasons so in looking at this program
which we love so much this is our
December 24th gentlemen this is our our
program where we love to answer your
questions we look forward to this this
uh program it gives us a chance to
answer your questions to see what is on
your mind and it really lets us know how
the Adventist Church and uh
non-adventist Christians because we get
questions from any number of people
across the world what's bothering them
what are they thinking about what are
they discussing what are the things that
are on your mind and heart so this is a
way that we get feedback into the
ministry that um Su TV is providing and
it lets us know where you are
spiritually and helps inform us as to
how we can not only answer your
questions but as we can structure our
ministry to help meet the needs of God's
people around the world so for that we
thank you and we encourage you to write
in your questions you can do so by
writing to tvom
tv.org
tvms M as in Mary tv.org and we will
answer your questions as thoroughly and
as quickly as we can we don't get to too
many questions per program we're going
to try to speed that up a little bit but
by the same token we want to do do
difference to your questions and not
just rush through them take the time to
study take the time to answer them uh as
the Lord gives us strength we will
answer them from the word of God if an
answer can indeed be found Pastor David
Salazar if you would please answer or
ask God's blessing upon today's program
then we'll get started
certainly gracious Heavenly Father we
come before you knowing that you are a
loving father and you want to bestow
upon us the gift of your holy spirit so
that we may be able to be taught and
guided to all truth and Lord as we are
in our in ourselves unable to answer
many of the questions we only come to
the source of wisdom which is you and
your word so we pray that you will give
us us discernment give us the right
words and may your words speak through
us and bring answers to the questions
that are dear friends are who are
watching are seeking we pray that you
will be with us we thank you once again
in Jesus holy name amen amen amen in my
enthusiasm I did not formerly introduce
uh the panel today Pastor David Salazar
who you know very well and of course
Pastor Steven bore our founder and our
principal speaker I'm CA Murray and
again our pleasure to be with you on
this particular program our first
question comes to us from Tisha this is
a subject that we have touched on before
but uh we choose to to uh just uh tap on
it just a little bit today again she
asks how should Farmers handle Sabbath
and taking care of animals like a Dairy
Farmer or a chicken farmer uh there are
things that have to be done each and
every day gentlemen
well the qu the answer actually it's
it's right there where she mentions
there are things that you cannot do uh
you know from one day to other in other
words you have to do it every day you
have to feed them and you might have to
put water and what not or let them go
out uh to to walk whatnot those are
things that you cannot prevent the
animal from doing to you know not to
give them water or food would be
actually a sin would actually be a an
abuse of a creature of God therefore we
are to
definitely give them the ability to eat
to walk to go you know in the field or
what not that is not something that the
Commandment forbids the Commandment
forbids for us to do any work that could
have been done any other day of the week
in other words what we cannot do we
cannot prepare or do preparations for
ahead of time that is a allowed but any
other thing that we can actually do
during the six days of work any type of
Duty or or or or work or labor that we
can do in the other days of the week we
are to do that and and you know we will
keep the seven day holy so uh it's not
really about us uh not taking care of
animals as far as feeding or giving them
water or or even opening the doors for
them to go out it's really laboring and
doing those things that uh could have
been done uh in in the other days of
week but we choose to don't Sabbath
that's when it becomes a transgression
and God cares so much about Beast a
burden that he even says don't make them
work on Sabbath in uh Exodus CH 23 and
verse 12 it says six days you shall do
your work and on the seventh day you
shall rest that your ox and your donkey
May rest and the son of your female
servant and the stranger may be ref
refreshed so um even the animals are
supposed to enjoy a Sabbath rest amen um
so you know can you reduce the amount of
workload with your beasts on Sabbath if
you can you should but for example cows
they have to be milked on Sabbath
there's no other way to do it they have
to be milked it would be uh really
disservice to them not to uh but you
know it doesn't mean that we can do any
kind of work on Sabbath that we could do
it as you said um the day before or the
day after right right mhm uh years ago
when I passed it in the northeastern
conference the first Elder of the
Saratoga Springs New York 7 Adventist
Church was at that time a Dairy Farmer a
large uh farm he had and uh he had to
duck out sometimes a little early
because he had to milk those cows each
and every day you just couldn't have
your cows sitting that were not milk so
uh that's understood uh when I was on a
j conference executive committee then
called we wrestled with um uh
stipulations for Adventist workers uh in
Adventist hospitals on Sabbath uh no
electric surgeries were done if if it
could be put off for another day but if
someone came in with an emergency well
you dealt with that emergency it's
lawful to do good on the Sabbath but if
there was something that could be done
tomorrow uh you did it tomorrow you did
just the necessary things on Sabbath to
maintain health and life and comfort of
of your patients and so I think those
are good rules to go by uh when you're
trying to determine what should be done
on on Sabbath
amen thank you so much uh Tisha for that
particular question now we meet Sherry
who is writing to us or Sheree no I
think it's Sherry writing to us from
Houston Texas and uh hello Sherry thank
you for writing um how is this passage
to be taken uh for those those who have
fallen away I think she is referring to
Hebrews chap 6 verse4 maybe um which is
the the problematic text part of that
that that uh text um she says are they
no longer able to be regenerated and
made alive in Christ or does this mean
they never were quickened in Christ to
begin with and this is a a text that uh
that confounds and and gives some people
trouble uh it seems to me most people
have fallen away from Christ is this a
Broadband of what to be followers
destined to stay on the Broadway to
destruction let's read Hebrews chapter 6
and verse 4 or Pastor would you prefer
we read it reread it all so we get the
whole context let's read chapter 6 veres
1-8 which gives us the context okay
we'll read the whole
thing okay um in HEB Hebrews chapter 6
I'm reading from the new King James and
the Bible says Hebrews 6 beginning at
verse verse one therefore leaving the
discussion of the elementary principles
of Christ let us go on to
Perfection not laying again the
foundation of repentance from dead works
and of Faith towards God and the
doctrine of baptisms of laying on of
hands of Resurrection of the dead and of
Eternal judgment and this we will do if
God permits for it is impossible for
those who were once enlightened and have
tasted the Heavenly gift and have become
partakers of the Holy Spirit and have
tasted the good word of God and the
powers of the age to come if they fall
away to renew them again to repentance
since they crucify to them themselves
the Son of God and put him to open shame
I'm in verse seven for the Earth which
drinks in the rain that often comes upon
it and bears herbs useful for those by
whom it is cultivated receives blessing
from God but if it Bears thorns and
Briars it is rejected and near to being
cursed whose end is to be burned
H powerful set of
texts yeah you know there are several
things that we can say about this
passage first of all the Apostle Paul
here is
addressing uh a lack of growth a stunted
growth of the Christian uh because he
says we're supposed to leave the
elementary principles of Christ you know
the ABCs if you please uh kindergarten
or prime primary school because he
speaks about uh you know repentance from
dead Works Faith toward God baptisms
laying on of hands Resurrection Eternal
judgment those are the
basics um and then he goes on to say uh
that it is impossible for those who once
and by the way the question asks whether
these people were never quickened the
fact is that they were they were they
were because verse four makes it very
clear for it is impossible for those who
were once enlightened enlighted yes and
have tasted the Heavenly gift and have
become partakers of the Holy Spirit and
have tasted the good word of God and the
powers of the age to come if they fall
away now is this talking about uh a
single event in the life of a person no
it's speaking about people who should
have grown they should have progressed
in their Christian life but they have
stunted growth and we know that because
of verses s and 8 for the Earth which
drinks in the rain that often comes upon
it mhm and bears herbs useful for those
by whom it is cultivated receives
blessing from God but if it Bears thorns
and briers notice it receives many times
the blessing but it Bears thorns and
Briars it is rejected and near to being
cursed whose end is to be burned burn uh
so it's saying that if you allow your
growth to become
stunted uh even though you have been
enlightened
you will fall away uh according to the
passage and that is a very um solemn
warning in a sense too to many who have
embraced the truth we are walking with
the Lord or we're growing in Christ in
knowledge of of Christ but instead of
showing fruits of righteousness growth
in victories in you know reflecting more
and more and each day closer to growing
closer to the Christ and showing his
character his love his care care for
others we produce thorns and we know and
and and really fruits of of the enemy in
thata scenario we are going to be as
Paul warns us against we will you know
we will depart to never come back and
that's the danger you know it's the more
light that you have the more you have to
reject
to not give that fruit of the spirit and
I believe that this is why Paul speaks
that way really tells you you know if
you are not growing as Pastor you were
mentioning if you're not growing in
Christ if you're not growing in in in
that knowledge of Jesus and the the
experience of your life being going
along with what you're learning you are
in the danger of being eventually being
rejected and you won't be you know it
says it's going to be impossible for you
to be to turn again to to come back and
that's the the biggest concern that we
have to have is like Lord help me to
grow and as I grow help me to maintain
that growth and not get staggered you
know there is in this text this group of
passages a something to be very aware of
and frankly be fearful of but they're
also is a great promise here if you just
read verse four for it is impossible for
those who have once been enlightened you
can get stuck on
that but you've got to read the entire
passage which assures you that God is
not a one anddone God that the rain will
come periodically the call will come
periodically the blessings will come
periodically so don't be so afraid of
the impossible part that you forget that
God is a loving God God is a persistent
God God will track you down he will
chase you he will call you and call you
and call you uh uh I know of a woman who
prayed for her husband 34 years and I
had a chance to baptize him he lived he
lived in the church I think 6 months and
then he passed my own father 30 days and
then he died after a lifetime of running
from the Lord so don't be so uh over
impressed with the impossible part be
impressed that the rain is coming and
the rain comes again and the rain comes
again and the rain comes again and the
rain comes again and God will do
everything remember God is trying to get
you in not keep you out and he will do
all that he can short of breaking the
law to save you Pastor even even verse
eight the last verse that we read uh
gives hope like you were mentioning
because it says but if it Bears thorns
and Briars it is rejected and near to be
being cursed in other words even at this
point it hasn't been cursed yet but it's
near to being cursed uh so you know
These Warnings that God gives us us is
for the purpose of waking us up yes and
making sure that we don't go down this
road yeah it's not to intimidate us or
to scare us so wake us up so that we get
back on the straight and narrow and we
continue our growing process and not
have stunted growth yeah we are in
television I remember years ago making a
presentation at General Conference and I
I I said you know I'm so glad that the
Lord judges us on the video and not the
snapshot you know uh if you take a
snapshot of a person at any point in
their life they could be in any amount
of disrepair but God doesn't take that
one snapshot and judge you on that he
takes the video he takes the Long View
of your life yesterday today he takes a
Long View and judges you on the video
not the sh snapshot for which we can be
thankful and very very amen amen I I
suppose there's another perhaps just
maybe digging a little deeper in these
these verses here something that came to
my mind as I read verse uh five in
speaking of of those who have tasted the
good word of God and the powers of the
world to come in other words it's it's
almost also a direct more warning to
those that have been in exalted
positions who have been called to be
ministers pastors preachers of the truth
uh that have had that experience of
receiving the Holy Spirit who have
partake of that experience of leading
all to the to the
truth in in some degrees I feel that
it's also giving a a warning to them
that have being you know blessed and
being enlightened that if they don't
realize that if they stop growing and
they start to allow their fruits to
become roten with sin and and and evils
of this world they are actually bringing
and putting Christ the son of God to
shame and crucify again so it's it's
really a warning for the more Delight
you have the more you have given upon
you the more blessings you have to be
very mindful to not turn away from that
growth from the source of Christ and end
up being in open shame so it's is really
like you mentioned a warning and I think
it's it's even more directed especially
to to those that are in leadership
positions and ministers so anyway well
done thank you P thank
you next we go to Norway and uh this is
always Pleasant this is Mario in Norway
the question is I am wondering why the
women were unclean for twice as long
after child birth if they got a daughter
instead of a son and they are referring
to Leviticus 12:
2-5 um do we want to read that so that
they can get a context I hate to refer
to text and then begin to talk on them
and not read the text for those who
uh may not be familiar with them so
let's look at
Leviticus 12 2-5 Pastor Salazar would
you read that for us pleas absolutely it
says there speak unto the children of
Israel saying if a woman have conceived
seed and born a man child then she shall
be unclean seven days according to the
days of the separation for her infirmity
shall she be unclean and in the Eighth
Day the Flesh of his foreskin shall be
circumcised and she shall then continue
in the blood of her purifying three and
30 days and shall touch no Hollow thing
nor come into the sanctuary until the
days of her purifying be fulfilled but
if she bear a ma child a woman you know
female then she shall be unclean two
weeks as in her separation and she shall
continue in the blood of her purifying
three score and six days and and when
the days of H PR fine are fulfilled for
a son or for a daughter she shall bring
out a lamb of the first year for a burnt
offering and of young P pigeon or a
turtle dove for a sin offering unto the
door of the Tabernacle of the
congregation andto the priest so there
you have it for a Manchild seven days
then she could take him to circumcision
and then she'll be two weeks uh for 20
um what do it says there exactly for
20 uh um for I'm sorry 33 days she was
to be uncleaned and then if she has a a
woman um a daughter 66 she will be 66 uh
two weeks un clean and 66 days twice as
much tce as much so what is the context
there why for a female and twice and a
man less or half the answer I got to
this this question actually my my eye
doctor for for many many years Dr
Michael liberman uh I said I had 13
surgeries while I was in New York his
dad was an orthodox Rabbi and we used to
you know while he's dilating me we we
talk and talk and talk um and I'm
curious because what he told me was that
he said when when women are born because
of the the anatomy of women there is
some blood in the vaginer area of the
child uh and so the the the double
impurity was to account for uh uh the
the vaginal area of of of the child
female child which had some blood so
there was another 33 days now that's
what his Rabbi father told him and uh
that's what he he explained to me well
the bottom line is that Father Knows
Best God knows best and some of these
ritual
specifications uh I don't think we'll
understand until we get to the kingdom
absolutely uh you know because uh there
there are so many prescriptions and
proscriptions in the levitical system
that uh you know I have I was going to
say if you asked me to speak first I was
going to say
pass because I I don't really other than
the explanation that you gave I don't
have one but God has one and so you know
God uh H has a better knowledge than we
do absolutely and so we just have to
abide by What God Says and this is a as
a mix of a health and religious you know
ceremony so it's it's dealing with some
aspects of Health you know of of what
God knew they needed to keep for the
camp you know the camp of Israel to to
be uh ped from disease from any any
stress on the woman that had have given
birth and also there's an aspect of you
know the circumcision and the ceremonial
that we truly you know can only see but
we cannot fully understand why there ins
and out you know but there could be a
very likely reason on the blood issue as
the blood was something that could not
come into the sanctuary so that could be
a sign you know a reason why the there's
a twice the length but as you mentioned
pastor examing with you you know the
Lord really knows exactly all the
details you know it's it's a really
interesting question but we can't really
give Mar
a full answer to that you know it just
goes to show that we don't have answers
to all the questions not all of them all
the questions we we know this that I
mean you had depending on whose numbers
you look at three to five million people
traveling through through the desert for
40 years you had to have some very
strict Health regulations to keep
disease uh from running rampant in that
Community uh disposal of waste dead
bodies uh bodies in still water as
opposed to bodies in moving water you
know you have to have very very strict
um Health laws and regulations that had
to be followed or that Community could
wipe itself out through Disease by un
unhealthful uh Health practices so a lot
of the Mosaic law were religio SL Health
practices that were practiced uh by by
those people and this perhaps is is
certainly one of them another
interesting thing you know that just
came to my mind about these verses is
that you know the God is speaking to us
or speaking to the children of Israel in
this case specifically and he's giving
them instructions based on gender you
know if it's a male and if it's a female
and there's more care if you will if if
I could say that for a female you know
for the mother to to be uh taken care of
that female child they needed to be uh
you know kept I guess in a more of a
secluded area or they were not to be
contaminated they couldn't have people
coming into the tent you know visiting
the little child like we do today you
know we have a baby everybody comes the
aspect also is of protection of caring
for the baby and the mother so maybe
there's also that aspect that we don't
know exactly nevertheless uh I do find
it interesting as well that you know God
is very peculiar about males and females
about gender identity and you know it's
important that we understand that the
Bible has always been consistent in how
God sees the role of a woman and the
role of a man and the reasons why there
is that distinction being you know two
genders and and be different so anyhow
just a thought thought
there very good pastor the bottom line
is we don't have a clear answer to this
question anything that we do say is
speculation opinion op opinion yes
indeed and it's good sometimes we get
questions that we just don't have the
answer to um uh particularly things that
deal with with with some of these little
more touchy issues but we thank you for
the question we don't really have time
to get into another question so let me
encourage you to send in your questions
again to TVM tv.org that is TVM tv.org
and we will answer them just as fast as
we can and as thoroughly as we can and
if we don't have an answer we are not
too proud to say we don't have an answer
we don't know everything we know a lot
but we don't know everything nobody
knows everything uh there's much more we
will learn as we get to Glory we'll be
studying for the rest of Eternity some
of the wonders of the things of God so
uh right now we see through a glass
Darkly but God has made his word
available to us and we thank him for
that well amen our time has fast slipped
into eternity allow me in closing to
wish you both Grace and peace wisdom and
strength in Jesus name God bless you
we'll see you again soon byebye and God
God
[Music]
bless